ser guatemalteca a mucha honra ser mamá
de dos niñas sanas en este país es un
verdadero privilegio en los últimos 20
años de mi vida he estado expuesta a los
proyectos locales más interesantes que
pueden ustedes imaginar he sido en
algunos casos colaboradora en otros
casos de espectadora pero de todos estos
proyectos se ha aprendido muchísimo y de
todos aquellos guatemaltecos que han
liderado estos proyectos y que
compartiendo su experiencia conmigo de
forma muy generosa han sido parte
esencial de mi vida laboral
hoy en día ellos son empresarios
diseñadores creativos en guatemala
en la universidad yo no estudié
administración de empresas no estudié
negocios no estudié mercadeo estudié
ciencia política y jamás me imaginé
verme como una empresaria
trabajé en los últimos años de mi vida 7
en una de las empresas más conocidas de
moda en guatemala y otros 7 en un museo
textil maravilloso un oasis en la ciudad
de guatemala el de mi familia no es una
familia de empresarios y yo siempre me
imaginé que los empresarios eran
distintos que habían estudiado algo
diferente que quizás habían empezado
muchísimo más jóvenes pero la vida
siempre nos da oportunidades para
reinventarnos
hace 5 años con 40 años cumplidos decidí
destinar todos mis ahorros y toda mi
energía a un proyecto que empezó
realmente interviniendo piezas locales
para mis hijas y para mi casa y luego
poco a poco se fue transformando en una
pequeña empresa donde lo que yo buscaba
era crear ropa para niños y artículos de
decoración todo inspirado en nuestro
país guatemala y todo
buscando siempre tomar los objetos los
materiales y las técnicas locales para
transformarlos en piezas funcionales y
en piezas contemporáneas con el tiempo
aquella idea con la que literalmente yo
buscaba ir en busca de mis sueños y
estar cerca de mis hijas para poderlas
inspirar de primera mano estar cerca de
ellas y que ellas entendieran el trabajo
el entusiasmo la disciplina que esto
necesitaba se convirtió en un proyecto
que cambió el ritmo de mi vida el rumbo
de mi vida y el de muchas mujeres con
las que trabajo actualmente
muy al inicio de la historia conocí a
una persona que marcó mi vida en una
corta conversación cuando yo me acerqué
a esta persona y le pedí que te hiciera
para mí una sexta que yo necesitaba para
mi proyecto y sentí como que esta
persona no entendía muy bien lo que yo
le estaba diciendo y me dijo
pero qué es lo que usted quiere señor al
final lo que yo quería era que esta
persona dedicará su tiempo y que yo que
me diera una suma con la cual yo podía
estar tranquila de que el día que yo
regresaba él me iba a entregar el
producto que yo le había encargado
entonces la formula la pregunta y le
dije mira yo lo que quiero es que tú me
des una suma con la que tú te sientas
contento y que cuando yo vuelva dentro
de unos días tú dejes de hacer lo que
estás haciendo y me entregues me encargo
y entonces percibí que esta persona
realmente había entendido lo que yo le
había dicho y me preguntó
entonces señor lo que usted me está
preguntando es cuánto quiero yo ganar
pues sí
pero me pregunto pero para mi bolsillo o
para mi alma y a mis 40 años yo
realmente tuve un momento de lucidez y
entendí que definitivamente yo le iba a
pagar para su bolsillo pero yo quería
llegar también a su alma en mi familia
siempre se dijo y siempre escuché el
trabajo dignifica y en ese momento
realmente tuve claro su significado
con el tiempo el negocio se fue
diversificando y entonces tuve la
oportunidad de conocer a muchos otros
artesanos y conocer muchos otros oficios
y los clientes empezaron a llegar y en
ese momento tuve la oportunidad que una
de mis mejores clientas se asoció
conmigo y se volvió una amiga
maravillosa y una compañera en este en
este proyecto en el que estoy
actualmente la empezamos a producir más
y la demanda empezó a crecer y entonces
como en todo negocio que empieza nos
tuvimos que enfocar porque realmente el
que mucho abarca poco aprieta
tuvimos que enfocarnos y tuvimos que
decidir cuál era el producto los
productos que nos eran más rentables y
que realmente iban a tener más éxito y
entonces decidimos que era la cestería
plástica que en aquel momento era una
colección inspirada en varias piezas en
organizadores en bolsos en otro tipo de
artículos siempre hechos y tejidos como
las tradicionales canastas de mercado
que existen en nuestros países
latinoamericanos llenos de color
con el tiempo les agregamos cuero les
agregamos pompones y bueno y lo demás ya
se vuelve historia se volvió un producto
aceptado que se trabaja en muchas
comunidades de nuestro país
pero en el camino nos dimos cuenta que
las canastas eran hermosas sí pero que
les faltaba algo les faltaba esa
historia tras ese story behind y
entonces descubrimos que estas canastas
podían ser tejidas también en plástico
reciclado
el proceso puedo contarles que ha sido
muy largo pensamos que nos iba a tomar
un poco menos de tiempo pero
y nos dispusimos realmente a entender a
entender sobre el plástico sobre las
posibilidades que habían en nuestro país
ha habido muchísimas pruebas y
muchísimos errores quiero contarles
comprendimos por qué es tan importante
la sostenibilidad y el porqué de la
circularidad quizás para otras
generaciones estos términos son mucho
más naturales y vienen y son más
orgánicos en sus vidas pero a nosotros
nos costó entender y nos encantó la idea
de poder tener un proyecto con productos
que realmente aportarán a la
sostenibilidad de nuestra comunidad y
del planeta donde vivimos
podemos confirmar que trabajamos ya
piezas y las comercializamos piezas
tejidas a mano por más de 350 mujeres en
el interior del país y están hechas con
filamentos plásticos certificados hechos
de 97% plástico reciclado por consumo
exclusivamente para nuestra marca ya
específicamente [ __ ] que es polietileno
de alta densidad el 3% restante son
pigmentos que le dan color a estos
filamentos esto nos tardó muchos años en
conseguirlo pero realmente el esfuerzo
vale la pena en guatemala somos una
marca reconocida que apoya a muchas
mujeres ya sus familias y lo más
importante acá como mujer y como mamá es
entender que estas mujeres guatemaltecas
tienen necesidades muy similares a las
mías a la de muchas mujeres y madres que
están aquí presentes
con este tipo de proyectos las mujeres
aunque son capacitadas en centros
comunitarios muy cercanos a sus hogares
vuelven a sus casas y trabajan en sus
casas cerca de sus hijos cerca
sus familias sin desatender su hogar su
alimentación higiene familia y con el
tiempo ellas se empoderan se dan cuenta
de lo valiosas que son estas mujeres
normalmente no recibían una remuneración
no trabajarán no trabajaban fuera de
casa y este tipo de proyecto les permite
a ellas recibir una remuneración tener
valor y por otro lado ser inclusive
económicamente independientes sin duda
el trabajo dignifica y este tipo de
proyectos nos lo demuestran día a día
todo esto pienso yo ha sido el resultado
de hacer las cosas bien pero sobre todo
de no perder nuestro norte nuestro norte
era sin duda crear un negocio crear un
proyecto que fuera beneficioso para
nosotros definitivamente para nosotros
para nuestro bolsillo para nuestras
familias pero que también pudiéramos en
el camino ayudar a nuestro país a ayudar
a otras mujeres que como nosotros
estaban buscando sueños y buscando
mejorar su vida y las de sus familias
durante el camino tuvimos muchísimas
veces la oportunidad de alejarnos de los
procesos sostenibles y de los procesos
innovadores que por su naturaleza pues
son más complejos son más lentos
inclusive son más caros pero entendimos
que definitivamente cuando vivimos en un
planeta interconectado donde nuestras
acciones tarde o temprano van a
repercutir en nuestras familias o en
nuestras comunidades nos dimos cuenta
que teníamos que buscar soluciones un
poco más grandes apuntar y soñar un poco
más en grande todos deberíamos proponer
soluciones y las soluciones realmente
surgen de nuestros aprendizajes de lo
que hemos vivido de lo que hemos sentido
de la gente que está cerca de nosotros y
muchas veces incluso de nuestras
pasiones y de nuestras frustraciones
cuando hay algo que nosotros queremos
cambiar tenemos que proponer soluciones
no podemos dejar que alguien más las
busque por nosotros y en nuestro caso
con mi socia esta es una forma nuestra
de proponer una solución a este tsunami
del plástico
que todos queremos eliminar de nuestro
planeta pero en el camino tenemos que
buscar soluciones intermedias y se valen
todos podemos proponer las la vida es
una escuela y todo lo que aprendemos nos
sirve tarde o temprano
no digo que haya sido un camino fácil
pero definitivamente vale la pena
contamos hoy con aliados estratégicos
otros empresarios con los que reciclamos
ya nuestro plástico y podemos producir
nuestros propios filamentos plásticos y
trabajamos bajo la sombrilla del
comercio justo con muchas comunidades en
el interior del país
más que nada en rabinal baja verapaz en
chajul quiché aquí muy cerca en san
pedro' las huertas y en otras
comunidades de guatemala
y recientemente estamos capacitando a un
gran grupo de mujeres en la ciudad de
guatemala en el relleno sanitario de la
zona 10 y esto nos da muchísima
satisfacción nuevamente mujeres en busca
de poder acción en busca de sus sueños
de crear y tener una vida sostenible
realmente hoy me siento muy honrada y
muy agradecida de hoy sí poder decir que
hoy me siento una empresaria soy una
empresaria social y me siento tranquila
y orgullosa de poder impactar a muchas
otras mujeres como yo muchas otras
madres como yo en este país con ellas
queremos crecer queremos crecer juntas y
queremos para nuestros hijos que éste
sea nuestro legado la sostenibilidad es
una elección y todos deberíamos optar
por ella
no hay
los invito a todos a subirse a este tren
de la sostenibilidad porque al final
estamos interconectados y sus acciones
van a impactar van a impactar los a
ustedes a sus familias tarde o temprano
para mí este negocio ha sido una
verdadera aventura una escuela de vida
todos los días y en los últimos años
definitivamente ha resultado de gran
beneficio para mi bolsillo y para el de
mi familia pero sin lugar a dudas este
tipo de proyectos esta experiencia más
que a mi bolsillo alimentado a mi alma
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]